blick on passe maintenant à notre second
débat vous le savez plus prospective
débat de société qu'on souhaite
déconnecté de l'actualité du jour avec
ce soit un constat le secteur du
numérique pollue si c'était un état se
serait le sixième émetteur de gaz à
effet de serre de la planète comment
inverser cette tendance première réponse
à guillaume bertrand
ici chacun de nos petits gestes en ligne
polluer la planète chaque fois que nous
répondons à un mail que nous consultons
nos smartphones ou que nous cherchons
notre site préféré sur internet nous
émettons des gaz à effet de serre nous
consommons de l'électricité un mail
envoyé c'est par exemple 20 grammes de
co2 autant qu'une ampoule allumée
pendant une heure une requête sur un
moteur de recherche pendant une minute
équivaut à 100 watts rien que sur google
sur une année les recherches internet
mondiale consomme autant d'électricité
que la norvège
ait enfin si l'on prend le réseau social
facebook ses utilisateurs et met en une
année 645 millions de kilogrammes de co2
l'équivalent de 640 5000 vol paris new
york et ça c'est sans compter la
fabrication de tous les matériaux du
numérique qui pollue tout autant
il faut savoir typiquement qu'industrie
de production des semi conducteurs qui
est basé vous le savez en asie très
majoritairement un petit peu aux états
unis
consomment énormément de ressources donc
notamment de l'eau et que l'eau c'est
une ressource si elle est renouvelable
vidal est épuisable on pourrait aussi
parler d'une décharge qui est très connu
au ghana où se retrouvent
malheureusement en fin de vie une grosse
partie de nos déchets électroniques
qu'on sait malheureusement très mal
recycler certaines entreprises cherchent
à créer des équipements plus économes
notamment pour les data center ses
grands centres de stockage et de
distribution de données qu'il faut
constamment refroidir avec de l'air
conditionné par exemple et qui sont donc
très gourmands en énergie la sncf s'est
doté d'un nouveau système où ces
serveurs sont directement refroidi par
un liquide une technique proposée par
sèche conessa fondateur d'immersion 4
d'autres liquides compte la chaleur
mille cinq cent fois mieux clair ce qui
permet d' un bon seulement enlever la
chaleur de ses serveurs n'a récupéré
cette chaleur et ses calories récupérées
des serveurs peuvent être soit éliminé
si jamais il y en a pas assez il
souhaite récupérer si jamais justement
il y en a suffisamment pour qu'elle
puisse être transformée en une autre
énergie et la particularité de
technologie c'est qu'en plus
jusqu'à 80% en france le numérique
représente aujourd'hui et 2% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre un
chiffre qui pourrait tripler d'ici 2040
le constat et les solutions face à cette
pollution invisible du numérique voilà
le thème de notre débat avec patrick
chaize bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur et l'air de l'ain à
l'origine de la proposition de loi qui
vise à réduire justement l'empreinte
environnementale de ce secteur
proposition adoptée à l'unanimité au
sénat hier soir céline lescop bonsoir ça
bienvenue vous êtes ingénieur en
informatique vous avez participé à la
rédaction des travaux du site project
sur la sobriété
numérique guillaume pitron bonsoir vous
aussi vous êtes journalistes et des
réalisateurs vous publiez l'enfer
numérique voyage au bout d'un likes et
aux éditions les liens qui libèrent avec
nous en visioconférence caroline néron
qui est directrice générale du mouvement
impact france bon soit le mouvement a
pas de français la fusion du mouvement
des entrepreneurs sociaux et de textures
good france voilà pour les présentations
guillaume daret toujours à mes côtés
évidemment je ne la partie peut-être là
c'est sympa le constat pour recommencer
patrick chaize je lisais en préparant
les missions que entre autres un c c'est
quand vous participiez à la marche pour
le climat que vous êtes dit faut il ya
quelque chose qui va pas qu'est ce que
vous allez constater jour là ce que j'ai
constaté c'est une chose tout à fait
simple c'est que il y avait beaucoup de
jeunes et que tous ces jeunes avaient
leur ce pensionnat la main en train de
se filmer ou voir même de renvoyer sur
la toile les images diffusées en direct
cette marche est
je me suis dit que il y avait une prise
de conscience à avoir et que sûrement
qu'il ne se rendait pas compte que en
faisant ce geste eh bien il était en
contradiction avec le sens de la marche
alors là il ya cette loi qui a donc été
votée
quatre priorités prise de conscience de
l'impact environnemental du numérique
promotion des usages numériques
écologiquement vertueux sanction de
l'obsolescence programmée et mise en
place d' engagement juridique
contraignant on fera un gros focus sur
l'obsolescence programmée peut-être sur
la prise de conscience s'est on parle de
pollution invisible dans notre débat
sais c'est pas c'est pas pour rien on a
un peu cette espèce de fantasme ou on a
appris le numérique dans cette espèce de
fantasme que tout est immatériel quoi d
une certaine façon oui alors que
justement le but du texte c'est de faire
en sorte que ce monde virtuel deviennent
du concret et du réel donc l'idée c'est
évidemment que l'on puisse avoir une
phase de sensibilisation d'éducation
pour que l'ensemble des utilisateurs
soient plus vertueux on va on va amorcer
des solutions ensemble peut-être
quelques chiffres l'empreinte carbone du
numérique dans le monde 4 % aujourd'hui
c'est une fois et demie plus important
que le transport aérien et l'empreinte
carbone numérique en france on parle de
2 % du total des des gaz des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ça pourrait
monter à 7% d'ici 2040 et c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est si les scop c'est
à dire que si on change rien dans si on
projette un peu nos modèles de
consommation d'électrification
massive
ça va exploser consommation matières
premières consommations d'électricité
consommation d'eau on l'a vu dans le
reportage oui tout à fait c'est une
caractéristique des travaux du site
project c'est justement de prendre les
choses dans leur ensemble et quand on
s'intéresse à la dynamique du système
numérique on voit que en fait tous les
indicateurs du numérique sont sont en
croissance les volumes de données
augmente le trafic de réseaux augmentent
le nombre d'objets connectés augmente le
nom de ressources minières dont on a
besoin guillon pourra en parler augmente
et quand on quand on s'intéresse à un
peu la dynamique des systèmes et qu'on
est face à un système qui a comme ça
tous ces indicateurs en augmentation
nécessairement c'est cette dynamique en
fait elle elle va nécessiter un effort
important pour être pour s'arrêter
simplement le streaming vidéo vous
parliez voilà du fait de diffuser en
direct c'est le streaming vidéo c'est un
pour cent des émissions mondiales de co2
ça aussi c'est une source du chief
projet guillaume pitron on parle des
vidéos mais alors la démonstration vous
faites dans votre dans votre livre c'est
d'ailleurs le le sous titre ses voyages
au goût d'un laïc c'est à dire qu'un
simple likes ou un post facebook ou ou
instagram y met en branle une mécanique
est une espèce de millefeuille internet
c'est un peu ça en fait ça revient le
défi qui se pose aux journalistes qui se
posent également à vous monsieur le
sénateur c'est comment est ce qu'on fait
prendre conscience de ces sujets là où
j'ai notamment et puis à nous tous qui
consommant ces outils internet tous les
jours et donc je me suis dit si je
devais raconter qu'est ce qui se passe
si je vous envoie un sms à vous monsieur
le sénateur ou un loup ou esquisse
quelques années la route de calais la
route de ce sms ou de se lie coût de
cette vidéo est en fait la notification
va traverser la planète en fait elle va
parcourir des milliers de kilomètres
passés par des centres de stockage de
données des câbles sous marins peut-être
des satellites
si on en croit les ambitions d'elon musk
d d antenne 5g enfin surtout 4g et
demain peut-être 5 g d box est donc en
fait si je vous envoie un un like et
bien en fait le like il va pas faire
trois mètres à 10 entre vous et moi il
va falloir des milliers de kilomètres et
donc ça peut être prendre conscience que
on en train de déployer ce qui est déjà
à mon avis la plus vaste infrastructure
spatiale sous marine terrestre que
l'homme n'est jamais édifié de
l'histoire de l'humanité pour envoyer
pour avoir une vie connectée et donc il
est une matérialité de ce monde virtuel
avec les impacts écologiques convient de
mentionner est bon on fera pas marche
arrière même s'il ya la question des
terres rares des métaux rares dont on va
parler d'eux et de la fin de leur
exploitation parce que ça c'est ça se
compte en décennies je crois donc on va
y revenir si ouais vous dirai ça en
détail il avait écrit vous avez écrit un
premier livre qui avait fait événement
sur ce thème mais voudrait entendre
caroline néron sur peut-être d amorce de
solution parce que c'est un peu pour ça
que take for good s'était créé inventé
promouvoir un numérique plus plus sobre
par exemple sur le trajet d'un le trajet
d'un sms ou le trajet d'un d'un lac est
ce qu'on peut pas imaginer
évitez de lui faire traverser trois fois
la planète quoi tout simplement les
solutions c'est
effectivement nous ont réuni toutes les
entreprises qui se sont donnés comme
mission de mettre le numérique aux
ossètes et des objectifs durables dans
ce cadre là les enjeux climat sont
évidemment hyper important et donc on
réunit autant des acteurs qui sont
engagés sur par exemple l'économie
circulaire et là on voit que les
solutions autour de l'économie
circulaire peuvent être boostée par le
numérique et est donc le numérique peut
servir aussi
d'accélérateur au développement durable
et puis tous les acteurs qui sont sur
les enjeux d'innovation sociale et
écologique via le numérique est donc
comment on crée et comment on invente
des nouvelles solutions
qui qui finalement au coeur l'enjeu
écologique et sociale et aujourd'hui
c'est finalement pas vraiment soutenu
développer encourager en france alors
l'économie ait lieu l'écosystème take
for good il grandit en france
mais aujourd'hui qu'on
souhaite avoir un crédit d'impôt
innovation recherche ou quand on
souhaite bénéficier d'un soutien du du
pays 1 est ce qu'on a
des choses vraiment des engagements qui
sont demandées sur ces enjeux numériques
ces enjeux écologiques pas vraiment
est ce qu'il ya réellement un focus qui
est donnée pour accélérer la mise en
place de d'innovation technologique
n'as-tu pas complètement donc on
collectivement on a des solutions qui
émergent dans le cloud
on a aussi des solutions bêtement de
location ont parlé haut et on va parler
de d'épuisement des ressources
tout les acteurs qui poussent sur les
enjeux de location des appareils soit en
train de se développer
et de manière assez
assez intelligente parce que ici se
soutiennent
pour ça tout petit peu trop longue
depuis les excuses et on n'est pas
parfaite c'est le paradoxe on fait une
émission ça reste évidemment la liaison
est pas est pas parfaite on est puni
parce que nous aussi on consomme là en
faisant une liaison com comme celle à
jour donnera la parole évidemment
caroline néron pour peut-être un peu
plus en détails au delà des grands
principes de nous donner quelques
solutions que que les entreprises
françaises sont en train d'inventer je
vais faire un focus 5 g et tient pour
pour pour avancer qui est en train de se
déployer en france est ce que c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle pour
l'environnement on écoute ce que ce
qu'en dit le secrétaire d'état chargé de
la transition numérique et des
consommations d'électronique ses
communications électroniques c'est le
terme exact de cédric au c'était il ya
un an écoutez le sur la question
environnementale nous considérons que la
5g et bénéfices au bénéfique de manière
vive le mental ne serait ce que parce
que les réseaux sont saturés dans les
deux ans à venir en 4g dans les grandes
villes et qu'on a le choix entre laisser
saturé même de la 4g qui consomme 20
fois plus que la 5g où m 5 g l'académie
consomme plus que de 1,5 g 10 à 20 fois
plus d'électricité ah oui exactement et
donc le cmh mal puisque plus vite non
mais les antennes 5g ont été conçu
originellement comme devant consommer
moins d'énergie alors c'est vrai ou pas
patrick chaize oui c'est vrai parce
qu'en fait justement par rapport à tout
le trajet qu'était expliqué tout à
l'heure pour un sms les antennes singer
ont dans leur système propre
l'intelligence pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que les aiguillages soit plus
court donc il ya effectivement donc un
gain énergétique qui qui est certain
dans l'utilisation de 5g d'être est
pourquoi on a besoin de la chine faisait
on peut peut-être le rappeler est ce
qu'on a vraiment besoin moi je vais vous
donner en fait ça dépend de comment est
ce qu'on regarde par quel angle on
regarde les choses quand on regarde
l'efficacité d'une antenne 5g tout seul
effectivement elle est plus efficace
qu'une antenne 4g il faut déjà voir
qu'elle se rajoute aux antennes katché
salle dans un premier temps on est un
pas les antennes 4g ensuite va falloir
renouveler les téléphones donc il faut
prendre en compte le fait est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs sur la crise des
semi conducteurs
l'arrivée de la 5g dans le monde fait
que ça accentue cette crise puisque ça
crée une demande sur ses téléphones et
c'est
toute la politique du secteur numérique
c'est d'abord la production des
téléphones des tablettes
qualifié la peau passé c'est une grosse
part est donc canton si on regarde juste
l'antenne 5 g c'est tout à fait correct
mais si on regarde le système dans son
ensemble et l'effet que l'introduction
de la 5g assure le système numérique
dans son ensemble ça fait augmenter ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
le dire rapidement caroline néron je
reviens vers vous merci de ta réponse un
peu plus courte que la que la précédente
la 5g pour les entreprises comme les
vôtres c est ce que c'est une obligation
économique est ce que vous pensez que si
on ne déploie pas en france on va
prendre trop de retard
franchement pas vraiment un nous
aujourd'hui les acteurs de la tech tant
qu'outil il ils défendent à la 5g
ils sont pas
obligatoirement accroché à un
développement qui puisse se faire
rapidement en france aujourd'hui il se
débrouille bien avec la 4g et donc il ya
eu pas mal de des changes mais voilà il
n'ya pas du tout de consensus pour
sketches et de ses acteurs aujourd'hui
guillaume pitron s comment est ce qu'on
peut
inventer une 5g sobre je sais pas si
haut si la question a du sens c'est
complètement contradictoire ce que la
saint-gilles va faire exploser la
consommation de données c'est normal ça
va permettre de multiplier les chiffres
divergent mais en gros par 45 la
production de données en 2035 par
rapport à 2020 donc tout ceci est
parfaitement compatible avec ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la sobriété mais vous
savez la sobriété ses prolongements
l'internet des années 2000 personne ne
va revenir vingt ans en arrière donc on
va laisser le mot sobriété il faut le
mettre de côté d informatisation des
numérisations sobriquet de ça c'est des
mots qui appartiennent à un passé dans
le canal
la question c'est la modération ce qu'on
peut ajouter pour aller dans ce sens là
c'est que la 5g le contraire elle va
accroître les usages demain on va voir
des téléphones avec la 5g qu'est ce
qu'on va en faire on ne sait pas encore
mais peut-être qu'on va davantage aller
dans le métavers a peut-être davantage
consommé la réalité virtuelle les jeux
vidéo et donc d'un côté vous avez une
consommation moindre électricité mais
donnez vous avez une forcément une
accroissement des usages et ce qu'il
faudrait prendre en considération c'est
l'ensemble de ces usages alors la 5g
elle est bonne pour plein de raisons
l'hôpital connectés
volontiers la 5g la voiture certainement
segment voilà il faut pas rejeter la 5g
en tant que tel après il va falloir voir
aussi qui va vers des usages peut être
tout à fait discutable pour la 5g et
donc la 5g les ni bonne ni mauvaise elle
est ce qu'on en fera n'oublions pas
automatique quand même parce que
certains qui ne regarde qui sont être
concernée que la 5g nakajima qui attend
de la 3g en france est encore du
territoire au delà de ce que c'est très
important c'est important de la mer je
la vends ce seuil a comparé la pollution
numérique c'est évidemment un sujet
important je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous regardent qui disent la
pollution numérique ok mais j'aimerais
d'abord et avoir du réseau du débit chez
moi à fra couronnant cry la fracture
numérique existe toujours emmanuel
macron on allait faire au cours de son
mandat un débat important en dix ans il
y aura quasiment plus de zones blanches
on va voir la fin du quinquennat où il
en est mais parler de la 5g c'est bien
n'oublions pas que certains n'ont même
pas la 3g jouer donc on pourrait se dire
la priorité c'est une escorte ce serait
plutôt de de réduire la fracture
numérique avant de démonter en fait
on est on est dans un monde
d'aujourd'hui qui fait un énorme usages
du numérique et ont comme le disait
guillaume on va pas forcément revenir en
arrière là dessus mais cette capacité
numérique on a aujourd'hui qui est déjà
très importante en fait elle est pas du
tout durable elle va se heurter à des
contraintes physiques sur l'énergie
aujourd'hui les gaffes appréhende par
exemple une très grosse partie de
l'énergie renouvelable face on le voit
déjà là sur les puces en ce moment on se
heurte à des contraintes physiques et
donc si on ne travaille pas à la
durabilité de cette capacité numérique
tel qu'on l'a aujourd'hui on risque de
la perdre en fait du fait de ces aléas
de ces aléas physique donc le l'idée
c'est plutôt de travailler à rendre ses
capacités qu'on a aujourd'hui durable et
justement partagé par la totalité de la
population plutôt qu'à à l'augmenter
elle à diversifier
voilà alors allez-y alors typiquement
c'est le sens en fête du travail qui a
été fait donc au céda et donc qui a été
conclu par cette proposition de loi
l'idée c'était de dire il faut
finalement par cette prise de conscience
qu'on sauve le numérique si on
était resté sur une position
qu'on connaissait le risque était que
haut on ne prennent pas conscience des
bons gestes par rapport à ce problème
environnemental par contre je suis pas
du tout en accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit sur sur la 5g parce que il ya
aussi toute une part qu'on oublie c'est
ce sont les externalités positives
utiliser du numérique c'est aussi éviter
des déplacements c'est faire en sorte
qu'on fasse des gains environnementaux
sur d'autres sujets mais ça s'équilibre
ça peut s'équilibrer et il faut qu'on
arrive à ces équilibres avec une prise
de conscience et avec une utilisation
raisonnée et raisonnable donc c'est
justement tout l'intérêt des travaux qui
sont faits c'est de mettre en évidence
les bons gestes des mauvais gestes et de
faire prendre conscience que bas plutôt
que de vous envoyer un sms tout à
l'heure
la pièce qui est juste à côté on vous
aurait amené un petit papier on aurait
fait ringard énergétique mais c'est tout
à fait vrai mais encore une fois c'est
pas pour vous être en défaut
c'est une réalité mais on le fait tous
mais si je peux me permettre sur les
externalités positif et sur cette
question en fait ce qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à faire c'est à mesurer les
choses qu'est ce qu'on gagne qu'est ce
que ça nous coûte et qu'est ce qu'on
gagne aujourd'hui on n'est pas outillé
pour mesurer l'ademe a déjà un certain
nombre de données à disposition mais
elles sont elles ont besoin d'être mises
à jour elles ont besoin d'être
entretenue donc les référentiels de
données sont assez faibles les normes
sur le sujet et les obligations de
publication sur ces sujets là de la part
des différents acteurs du numérique soit
encore assez assez faible et aller les
ingénieurs je suis un peu investi dans
l'enseignement supérieur sont pas formés
à ces sujets donc on peut pas
aujourd'hui partir de l'idée que le
numérique de toute façon va être bon
pour la transition sans être outillés
sur la mesure donc une déposition du
chiffre c'est vraiment d'être rigoureux
sur cette mesure est justement de
choisir les façons de faire du numérique
qui soit vertueuse à l'avenir caroline
néron il ya des startups françaises qui
se sont spécialisés justement dans la
dans cette idée de
de mesure de l'impact
tout à fait il ya des startups plusieurs
qui se sont spécialisés sur la mesure de
l'impact carbone
ce qui est hyper important parce que
déjà de manière générale il ya une
espèce de
de présupposer que et évaluer son
empreinte carbone serait très compliqué
pour toutes les entreprises alors que
finalement aujourd'hui grâce à ces
outils c'est plus simple et puis un
enjeu à identifier quels sont les bons
indicateurs je suis vraiment d'accord
avec lille vient dé dit quels sont les
joueurs à suivre pour
finalement abaisser son empreinte
environnementale de la tech et puis par
ailleurs globale sur sur d'autres enjeux
et ça l'enjeu de trouver les bons
indicateurs qu'ils soient partagés par
tous et d'être en capacité de les
mesurer
pour pouvoir les baisser finalement ça
c'est c'est un enjeu d'aujourd'hui sur
lequel ben nous on a on a commencé à
travailler on a fait un tête fort goût
de ce corps pour ça pour pouvoir aider
les entreprises à à l'évaluer qu'on
aimerait travailler qu'on va commencer à
travailler avec avec la bpi
voilà les les grands les grands
investisseurs publics et privés
pourraient utilement s'en saisir je
voudrais qu'on en vient à la question de
l'obsolescence programmée pâte richesse
c'est l'un des points importants du
texte qui a été voté hier l'obsolescence
des des objets il change quoi elle
change quoi cette loi en la matière bon
en fait je souhaitais évoquer d'auteur
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans donc
le coût environnemental du numérique les
terminaux pèse pour 80%
c'est vraiment la majeure partie donc du
coût environnemental
donc l'objectif c'est bien sûr de faire
rapidement des économies sur ce
secteur-là et donc de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse prolonger la durée de vie
de ces terminaux en comment durer faire
pour prolonger leur vie c'est aussi la
sensibilisation c'est donc l'éducation
mais c'est aussi éviter que et bien par
des mises à jour successives qui sont
donc nombreuses
vous en conviendrez
les capacités même du matériel soit
dépassé dire que si vous faites des
mises à jour que vous ajoutez toujours
des fonctionnalités dans votre matériel
votre matériel va donc arriver à son ca
limites de fonctionnement mais attendez
la loi française à pouvoir imposer aux
mesures aux producteurs de cesser les
mises à jour des limites et bien sûr
donc et notamment avec d'une notion qui
a été relativement intéressante c'est de
faire en sorte déjà le séparer les mises
à jour entre les mises à jours qu'on va
appeler mise à jour de sécurité et les
mises à jour de fonctionnalités et de
faire en sorte aussi qu'on puisse faire
des retours de mise à jour observe
aujourd'hui vous êtes passés de la mise
à jour 10 à la mise à jour 11 c'est fini
vous pouvez pas revenir en arrière là il
sera donné la possibilité de revenir à
la mise à jour 10 pour justement donc
donner à votre matériel mes capacités
qui correspondent à votre utilisation
guillaume pitron cette loi c'est un
progrès ce que la france se place un peu
en avance par rapport à d'autres pays
sur ces questions elles se placent
absolument n'avance ya pas de pays à ma
connaissance je parle sous le contrôle
de mes 2 mai 2,2 deux acolytes ici sur
ce plateau mais non effectivement pour
avoir fait le tour du monde de la
question de la pollution numérique et
des solutions également ce que
j'apprécie dans cette loi alors il ya
bien évidemment c'est tout n'est pas
satisfaisant notamment sur sur les
produits électroniques mais c'est qu'on
fait cette loi couvre l'ensemble des
grands des grands chapitres de pollution
le téléphone portable
le centre de traitement de données et
puis ça va également sur la question
d'éducation c'est très important de
commencer par éduquer les gens à ce
qu'est la pollution numérique puisque
c'est virtuel donc en ce sens c'est un
livre est un vrai progrès par rapport à
ce que font d'autres pays est-ce que
c'est pas vain s'il ya pas une démarche
au niveau européen ou mondial ya quelque
chose qui est fait au niveau de la
commission européenne ou au niveau que
certes on est peut-être en avance sur la
lutte contre la pollution numérique mais
est-ce que ça va pas être vu peut-être
comme un frein par les entreprises dans
la concurrence internationale
alors la commission européenne vient de
passer récemment une disposition
proposant notamment enfin indiquant que
les vendeurs de téléphones portables
sont pas obligés ne vont pas vendre
automatiquement les accessoires associés
au téléphone portable mois les écouteurs
est notamment les écouteurs alors c'est
vrai que ça paraît un peu limite sa
disposition puisqu'on parle juste de
l'accessoire en parle pas de s'attaquer
à la pollution même de l'objection de
chargeur unique non je crois aussi que
voilà c'est ça excusez moi c'est plus
précisément le chargeur unique mais
après je ne sais pas ce que vous en
pensez patrick chaize sur cette question
précisément je
vais prendre
moi je fais beaucoup de sensibilisation
internationale sur ces sujets là je peux
vous dire que le que la conscience sur
ces sujets là est en train d'augmenter
significativement aux états unis en asie
les grands fournisseurs internet
travaille sur ces sujets là ont des
données précises sur ces sujets sujet là
et et pardon je vous interromps riz est
ce que ce qu'ils nous vendent ces objets
jusque là on est sur les objets leur
modèle économique qui s'est créé sur le
le fait de renouveler l'objet sortir
ainsi les modèles tous les autres les
deux ans je crois que la durée de vie
d'un téléphone ses 23 mois en moyenne
c'est le modèle économisant revoit oui
bien sûr mais dans toutes ces
entreprises là vous avez des gens qui
sont maintenant conscients du problème
environnemental et qui ont à coeur de
effectivement de le résoudre et donc
justement la france grâce à ce tissu
associatif et 7 exerce cette expertise
qu'elle a développée sur le sujet au
contraire à l'opportunité de développer
une offre une expertise et d'être un peu
un leader finalement sur ces sujets là
la base de données de l'ademe par
exemple je ne crois pas qu'ils
d'équivalent dans d'autres pays
du monde et il faut cette petite avance
qu'on a peut aussi être vu comme
vraiment une opportunité pour pour
avancer c'est ce que nous font les fins
comme retour les fournisseurs et on a
enfin vraiment il ya enfin je pense
qu'on est très peu en avance en fait
voilà sept ans que
légèrement
le climat est clairement en train de
traverser la totalité de la planète
quand un holà dessus caroline néron joue
à réagir oui c'est juste pour vous dire
du côté des entreprises nous on est un
dock un réseau d'entreprises qui
représente un peu plus de 7000
entreprises en france par ailleurs on
est en lien avec évidemment plein
d'entreprises partout sur le territoire
qui sont pas obligatoirement aussi
engagé que les nôtres et on voit qu'il
ya une réelle prise de conscience et
finalement aujourd'hui elles ne savent
pas comment s'y prendre et plus elles
vont avoir des lois qui vont les
accompagner dans cette démarche plus
finalement elles vont prendre un temps
d'avancé sur la suite est ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit tout à fait juste on a
un enjeu aussi d'accompagner et
d'encourager les entreprises à s'y
mettre in fine et ça va leur permettre
d'avoir de nouveaux marchés de nouvelles
expertises parce que tout le monde va
devoir s'y mettre c'est évident donc
aujourd'hui c'est les vous les lois qui
vont dans ce sens enclencher un cercle
vertueux c'est ce que je retiens de ce
que vous venez de dire guillaume pitron
dans votre livre la guerre des métaux
rares vous aviez
voilà le creuset déjà enquêté sur sur ce
qu'ils étaient nos voiles à nos objets
nos téléphones portables au new
tablettes je disais tout à l'heure
la
l'utilisation la consommation de ces
terres rares de ces métaux rares on en a
pour combien de temps au rythme de
fabrication et de production de nos
téléphones et de tablettes à 10 ans des
métaux évidence ces métaux rares sont
diluées pas forcément rare c'est à dire
qu'on en trouve au fond des océans et
même sur la crête des astéroïdes c'est
pas demain qu'on ira sur les astéroïdes
mais les océans une entreprise métal ce
compagnies commencent à dire qu'il va
falloir extraire des métaux toutes
sortes de métaux dans les nodules
polymétalliques au milieu du pacifique
pour dit-elle le fabriquer des batteries
de voitures électriques et donc pourquoi
pas pour les batteries de téléphones
portables en fait c'est pas demain qui
aura plus un gramme de métal rare ou de
métal critique ou stratégiques l
extraire quelque part c'est la question
on a vraiment tenu un discours différent
dans certaines émissions dix ans il y en
a pour certains métaux y en a pour six
sept ans pour d'autres 40 ans balançoire
effectivement parce que si vous voulez
notre connaissance de ces gisements
évolué et donc à mesure que notre
consommation s'accroît la connaissance
des gisements également évolué les
techniques d'extraction évolue donc
c'est une course de vitesse en fait
entre l' explosion de la consommation et
les progrès technologiques ce qui fait
que c'est un peu comme le pétrole ça
fait 40 ans le pétrole quand on a pu
pour 40 ans donc les métaux rares ça
fait 40 ans qu'on aura plus pour 40 ans
à mon avis c'est pas une question
géologiques les limites elles sont
ailleurs à quel coût est ce qu'on ira
chercher ces métaux au fond de l'eau
font des affaires à quel coût économique
à quel coût énergétique qu
environnemental
et donc à quel coût l'acceptabilité
sociale le guen n'a aucune envie
d'extraire ces terres rares la france
n'a pas envie qu'on a extrait du lithium
au fin fond de l'auvergne le au pérou et
au nicaragua on n'a pas envie d'extraire
toutes sortes de métaux dans les sous
sols de ces pays et donc en fait j'ai
des limites qui sont pas des limites
géologiques sont des limites sociales
dès que ça d'acceptabilité sociale des
mines donc d'élite des limites
politiques et ce qui fait que je pense
que on s'arrêtera un jour d'extraire des
matières premières rares pour nos
téléphones portables
non pas parce qu'on n'aura plus mais
parce qu'on ne voit plus les extraire ce
sont des raisons à mon avis différentes
et donc les limites elles sont encore
une fois il ya je voudrais qu'on fasse à
il nous reste 5 6 minutes qu'on parle de
la com 26 qui se tient à glace qu en ce
moment il n'y a pas une échelle détails
avec des journalistes mais ont beaucoup
de mal à travailler et à accéder mais
des journalistes il ya aussi l'homme le
plus riche de la planète on écoute jeff
bezos
la question est simple winslow cadre
allons-nous travailler ensemble dans
cette salle - tu gardes est ce que nous
allons faire un travail acharné ensemble
pour offrir à nos enfants et petits
enfants un monde naturel meilleur
[Musique]
je sais que la réponse est oui
jeff bezos ce qui était invité par les
drs forestation en fait parce que amazon
participent au projet au grand projet de
de muraille verte qui va traverser le le
continent africain c'est une lescop à ce
que est ce que c'est le mieux placé pour
parler de sobriété numérique jeff bezos
quand vous l'entendez moi j'ai le
sentiment quand je regarde je lis quand
même pas mal d'articles sur lala com 26
que c'est pas le thème central de cette
coop ce dont on parle là depuis depuis
une demi-heure sur ce plateau sur le
numérique voix
le numérique c'est comme vouloir tenir
au début c'est 4 % des gaz à effet de
serre donc effectivement il reste 96 %
qui est très haut qui a donné il ya
d'autres urgences soit
ce qui caractérise au numérique c'est sa
croissance exponentielle 6% donc quand
on doit réduire de moitié à l'horizon
2030 je crois les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre au global et 15 secteurs
et dans une telle croissance c'est un
gros problème on peut pas atteindre les
accords de paris en ayant une telle
croissance sur le numérique ça c'est pas
possible après
concernant amazon va enfin déjà la
première chose c'est la question de la
transparence sur la mesure des émissions
des services qu'il propose voilà où il
progresse mais oui a encore des progrès
à faire et
oui voilà et donc on agit s'arrête là en
fait en fait je pense que pour jeff
bezos ce le numérique c'est la solution
parce que ça a virtualisé nos échanges
si jamais je vais à new york mais qu'en
fait finalement j'ai pas à new york pour
une réunion mais que je vais sur zoom le
gain écologique est absolument énorme et
donc une fois pour l'industrie de
l'environnement 2 du numérique la
question de sauver la planète et par
définition parfaitement cohérente ravet
avec les services qu'il propose on va
virtualisés nos échanges on va aller
vers cette dématérialisation qui va
permettre le découplage entre
l'accroissement des richesses et
l'impact de nos modes de vie sur
l'environnement mais ça ne tient pas si
on invente pas numérique - énergie
vertueux c'est long et ça commence à
être un vrai sujet au sein d'amazon
parce que vous avez au schéma zone chez
google des antennes et des employés qui
signe en fait des pétitions pour dire
mais qu'est ce que vous faites vous
directement pour limiter aux émissions
de gaz à effet de serre les émissions
directes donc on voit tout d'un coup que
ce discours qui consisterait à dire
numérique environnement vont de pair il
est remise en cause au sein même de ces
entreprises ça commence à devenir un
vrai sujet un vrai enjeu de réputation
pour ses entraînements je reviens vers
vous caroline béraud on a vu dans le le
reportage est bon on va dire un mot des
datacenter même si c'est parce qu'ils
polluent le plus c'est quand même là
aussi consommateurs d'électricité on a
vu dans le reportage consommateurs d'eau
il ya des solutions technologiques choix
qu'il ya des entreprises françaises qui
propose des data center immergez vous
pouvez nous en dire un mot de sa
pas vraiment parce que je ne connais pas
je ne connais pas exactement ça linux
océan spray leurs solutions
ah oui tout à fait c'est berger
datacenter
6,6 gg je les ai juste déconné mais je
peux pas vous en parler plus que
l'objectif n'était pas de vous coller un
pardon c'était je pensais que vous aviez
des infos sur sur eux mais ça c'est
intéressant les datacenter patrick
chaize parce que là aussi on peut
peut-être faire confiance au génie
humain la capacité à trouver des
solutions pour qu'ils soient moins
consommateurs d'électricité -
consommateurs d'eau pour soi réfrigérée
etc mais c'est un acte du texte de loi
qu'on a voté hier sire que le quatrième
axe c'est le lac ce infrastructures et
principalement data center pour faire en
sorte que là aussi on accompagne les
gestionnaires de ces de ses centres de
données à être plus vertueux d'un point
de vue environnemental avec des
incitations fiscales avec donc des
obligations de récupération de la
chaleur primaire donc ça fait vraiment
partie du travail que l'on a réalisé qui
s'est décomposée en plusieurs axes on a
voulu donc dans notre démarche en fait
faire en sorte que l'ensemble de la
chaîne des valeurs soient donc réfléchi
dans une dans un objectif partagé qui
est d'améliorer donc de façon aux
vertueux l'impact environnemental du
numérique il ya une deuxième loi qui a
été votée hier qui est passée un peu en
dehors des radars parce qu'il était le
sujet été intégrés dans le texte initial
pour des questions techniques que je
passerai
l'assemblée nationale donc modifier donc
c'est pas espère retrouver c'est un
sujet qui est la collecte des données
donc on a voté hier un texte qui doit
permettre notamment à l'arcep le
gendarme des télécoms de tous récupérez
faire de la collecte de données auprès
de l'ensemble des acteurs afin justement
de pouvoir donc avoir des mesures les
plus pertinentes possibles sur les
impacts environnementaux et ça c'est une
innovation importante qui va donc
intégrer la régulation le en
environnement et cette mesure je
l'espère fera école pour que d'autres
pays puissent s'en saisir et suivent
notre initiative merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
n'était pas que
désespérant et pessimiste il y avait
quand même quelques amorces de deux
solutions guillaume pitron je rappelle
le titre de votre livre l'enfer
numérique voyage au bout d'un laïc c'est
aux éditions les liens qui libèrent
merci encore à bientôt j'espère qu on
sente aura bientôt donc ça tient lieu de
sms on
va arrêter de s'envoyer des sms à
longueur de journée évidemment on va
suivre à très bientôt vos conseils à
très bientôt merci encore d'être venu
partager nos débats sur sens public
voilà moi je vous donne rendez vous
demain et puis vous avez un autre
rendez-vous avec l'actualité politique
c'est demain matin au rayonnement ceni
qui reçoit frédéric valletoux le
président de la fédération hospitalière
de france qui est aussi le maire de
fontainebleau